leaders and government representatives
of the 134 developing countries that
make up the largest intergovernmental
Alliance of the UN had a clear message
for the world's wealthiest Nations
regrettably what we have seen with the
advance of years is a consolidation of
power and wealth in the hands of an
absolute few
and that concentration is continued is
likely to be continued as a result of
the privatization of knowledge research
science and technology I've come today
with a simple message
that the hour is now
and the future is ours to grasp
U.N Secretary General Antonio guterres
issued a surprisingly strong criticism
of his own organization which he says
has led the global South down many of
today's institutions particularly the
United Nations security Council and the
Bretton Woods institutions reflects a
bygone area and I count on your group
who have long been champions of
multilateralism to step up to use our
power and fight
the principal aim of the meeting is to
address the global South's lack of
access to science technology and
Innovation China which is a supporter
but not a full member of the group
promised to increase cooperation
as the Chinese proverb says the strength
of Brothers is infinitely stronger when
they unite host president Miguel Dias
canel of Cuba made it clear it would be
an austere Summit and then too subtle
reference to his country's acute
economic crisis made worse by years of
U.S economic sanctions the group of 77
plus China is holding its Summit just
days before the annual meeting of the
U.N general assembly in New York more
than a coincidence it appears to be a
concerted effort to form a tighter
Alliance before presenting their demands
before leaders of the industrialized
world
the key challenge though is to agree not
just on a list of complaints but on a
concrete plan of action
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Havana
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera